bien mes chers collègues nous
poursuivons le cycle de nos auditions
sur le projet de loi de finance pour
2023 en accueillant en Sarah el Hairi
secrétaire d'État auprès des ministres
des armées et du ministre de l'éducation
nationale chargée de la jeunesse et du
service national universel et Madame
Marlène Schiappa secrétaire d'État
auprès de la première ministre chargé de
d'économie sociale et solidaire et pour
ce qui concerne la Commission de la vie
associative mesdames je vous remercie de
vous être rendu disponible pour venir
commenter à deux voix devant notre
commission les crédits mis à votre
disposition dans le PLF 2023 en
particulier ceux du programme 163
jeunesse et vie associative
avec un total de 837 millions d'euros
répartis en quatre entre quatre actions
le développement de la vie associative
les actions en faveur de la jeunesse et
d'éducation populaire le développement
du service civique et le financement du
service national universel ce programme
voit ses moyens augmentés pour la
cinquième année consécutive au-delà de
la progression de ces crédits sans doute
bienvenue cette audition est aussi
l'occasion pour nous de vous entendre
présenter les grands actes des actions
que vous souhaitez entreprendre en
faveur de la jeunesse et de la vie
associative je pense bien entendu à la
montée en charge du service national
universel nous avons plusieurs
occasions
nous avons parlé à plusieurs occasions
qui après avoir été fortement perturbé
par la crise sanitaire évidemment peine
encore à atteindre les objectifs
quantitatifs fixés par le gouvernement
nous interrogeons évidemment sur la
suite est-ce qu'il y aura une
généralisation du SMU je suis sûr que
notre rapporteur vous interrogera sur ce
sujet je pense aussi aux financement des
missions de service civique qui ne
bénéficieront plus comment 2022 des 200
millions d'euros
issus du programme cohésion de la
mission du plan de relance je pense
enfin au secteur associatif qui aurait
perdu près de 15% de ses bénévoles entre
2019 et 2022 selon une étude récemment
publiée par France Bénévolat et
recherche et solidarité les travaux
réalisés par notre commission mis en
évidence la fragilité des associations
et le rôle essentiel qu'elle joue dans
la création et le maintien du lien
social sur notre territoire que prévoit
donc le budget de 2023 pour leur rendre
le dynamisme que certains et certaines
ont semblent-ils perdues au cours des
deux années écoulées celle de la crise
sanitaire évidemment après votre
intervention je donnerai la parole à
notre rapporteur budgétaire frère
Jacques Bernard manié puis aux amateurs
des groupes et enfin aux autres membres
de la commission qui souhaitent vous
interroger je rappelle que cette
audition est captée et diffusée en
direct sur le site du Sénat mesdames les
secrétaires d'État je vous laisse à
présent la parole je ne sais pas qui
commence
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs collègues le programme
Jeunesse est via associatif que je porte
aujourd'hui avec ma collègue Marlène
Schiappa regroupe effectivement une
partie des crédits à louer en faveur de
la jeunesse et également du soutien
associatif comme vous le savez l'effort
budgétaire de la nation en faveur de la
jeunesse dépasse très largement et je le
dis chaque année le programme 163 bien
sûr puisque la jeunesse aujourd'hui son
budget est porté par l'éducation
l'éducation nationale l'enseignement
supérieur la culture mais ce programme
en particulier jeunesse et vie
associative c'est la partie de
l'éducation informelle celle dont on a
besoin pour accompagner nos jeunes et
appuyer le secteur associatif chaque
crédit de ce programme est une politique
publique qui bénéficie concrètement aux
jeunes sur nos territoires parce
qu'elles sont construites avec le monde
associatif et les services déconcentrés
mais en articulation systématique et
automatique quasiment avec nos
collectivités territoriales parce que
cette collaboration dans l'intérêt de
nos jeunes ne peut s'inscrire et
s'écrire comme cela agir pour la
jeunesse c'est prendre en considération
toute sa diversité l'accompagner tout au
long de son émancipation agir pour la
jeunesse c'est apporter des réponses
concrètes adaptées pour que chaque jeune
puisse trouver sa place et son chemin
agir pour la jeunesse et l'accompagner
vers l'autonomie en facilitant aussi
l'accès l'information lutter
concrètement contre le non recours c'est
aussi l'aider à se projeter dans dans
l'avenir on lui donnant les moyens de
penser et de construire son projet son
projet de vie agir pour notre jeunesse
et déployer des solutions aussi afin de
lui léguer et bien un avenir prometteur
et soutenable et refuser en tout cas les
déterminismes sociaux et territoriaux en
donnant à chaque jeune quel que soit son
origine sociale ou géographique les
mêmes chances de réussir de s'engager
agir pour la jeunesse et développer
cette société de l'engagement que nous
chérissons ou chacun et un pleinement sa
place et surtout la ressentir pour la
jeunesse c'est évidemment aussi
concrétiser la promesse républicaine du
vivre ensemble de la tolérance l'accès
au droit à l'éducation et le
renforcement de nos valeurs essentielles
je pense aussi évidemment à la laïcité
ces crédits liés aux politiques en
faveur de la jeunesse de l'éducation
populaire et de la vie associative
augmente de 65 millions d'euros ça
signifie 8,6% d'augmentation et ça a été
rappelé par le président pour atteindre
un objectif en tout cas un budget à plus
de 837 millions d'euros pour 2023 c'est
un budget à la fois important qui est
renforcé bien sûr mais qui est au
service de deux grands axes que je vais
vous présenter d'abord une forte
mobilisation pour favoriser l'engagement
nos jeunes c'est-à-dire on parlait de du
bénévolat mais c'est aussi comment on
les accompagne vers plus d'autonomie
plus d'opportunités et soutien
évidemment le développement de la vie
associative
ce programme est une fraction de
l'effort de la Nation pour soutenir
impulser innover mais aussi faire de la
coordination interministérielle pour
accompagner nos jeunesses c'est aussi
développer tous les aspects auxquels nos
jeunes aujourd'hui sont confrontés je
pense évidemment aux défis climatiques
aux questions de mobilité mais on
pourrait en parler pendant des heures je
fais le choix pour apporter un certain
nombre de réponses de m'appuyer sur
quatre mesures peut-être emblématiques
et plus particulières qui sont les
priorités de cette année la
structuration du secteur de l'animation
que vous connaissez tous et auquel vous
êtes confrontés suite aux remontées des
mers je pense au développement et au
déploiement du service national
universel monsieur le Président sur
lequel j'apporterai un certain nombre de
réponses bien sûr le soutien du tutorat
et du mentorat et enfin le développement
du service civique en particulier sur
l'animation de mémoire on a en novembre
lancer une sorte de mobilisation
générale des acteurs pour construire une
sorte de renouveau de l'animation et des
mesures ont été proposées 25 le 22
février dernier il y a eu deux grandes
catégories de mesures d'abord des
mesures exceptionnelles pour répondre à
la pénurie et c'était une demande de des
acteurs ça a permis par exemple de faire
une aide exceptionnelle pour lever le
frein financier de l'accès au BAFA de
200 euros accordé aux jeunes alors même
qu'on avait budgété 20000 aides on a eu
25 000 demandes et on a trouvé les
moyens de financer les 25000 demandes
compte tenues aujourd'hui de la
difficulté de la pénurie de recrutement
mais aussi l'engagement et la
reconduction du plan mercredi par
exemple qui a été conforté et enfin le
fait de réduire de raccourcir le délai
d'obtention du BAFA parce que en lien
avec les organisations de formation on
perdait un certain nombre de jeunes par
rapport à la durée ou à la tenue des
jurys en particulier il y a quelques
semaines j'ai signé également
l'abaissement de l'âge du début de
formation à 16 ans et j'ai eu l'occasion
de de visiter les premiers jeunes qui
commençait leur formation à 16 ans
puisque se prépare à encadrer des 17 ans
cet été un certain nombre de centres
aérés par exemple ces mesures sont
nécessaires utiles bien sûr elles
portent des fruits mais ça nous demande
aussi une transformation plus
structurelle en réalité du monde de
l'animation en s'appuyant d'abord sur la
confiance des parents c'est comment on
fait ce continuum éducatif entre
l'éducation formelle l'éducation
informelle comment on améliore aussi les
conditions d'attractivité de ces métiers
je pense évidemment elle a lutte contre
le temps partiel subit à la question du
parcours à l'évolution des parcours
répondre aussi à des craintes
aujourd'hui qui sont qui sont portées
sur quelles sont les formations pour
prévenir des violences sexuelles et
sexistes je pense en particulier aux
accueils collectifs de mineurs avec
hébergement et donc la démarche qui a
été la mienne c'est de mettre autour de
la table les acteurs de mettre en
lumière les meilleures pratiques d'abord
pour les répondre à ce besoin de
sécurité et de confiance
de l'autre côté c'est avec beaucoup de
détermination que nous travaillons sur
la reconnaissance de ces métiers du lien
qui sont aujourd'hui si essentiel avec
le déploiement du service national
universel nous arrivons à une sorte de
Momentum monsieur le Président j'ai eu
l'occasion de vendre votre commission de
présenter année après année les étapes
les évolutions les difficultés aussi
qu'on a connu aujourd'hui quand je dis
nous sommes à un momentum sous l'ancien
quinquennat on a fait plusieurs
expérimentations la délégation à une
association l'organisation très centrale
par la direction de la pièce de la djeva
donc la jeunesse la vie et de la vie
associative au niveau national en
s'appuyant sur au contraire les services
déconcentrés sur nos territoires mais ce
qui est certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
service national universel dans un
moment où nous vivons et bien une
accélération des défis des défis
climatiques nous avons eu un été avec
des catastrophes climatiques
particulièrement intenses je pense aux
inondations au feu ou encore à la
tornade dans le Pas-de-Calais il y a
quelques quelques semaines
des défis de cohésion nationale nous
avons une jeunesse pour une partie
d'entre elles qui ne se croisent plus
qui ne fait plus ensemble et qui n'a
plus de commun et donc comment recréer
susciter une culture de l'engagement
autour de valeurs communes mais aussi
augmenter la résilience de notre pays et
par le mode résilience je pense à cette
éducation à la sécurité civile je
pensais évidemment au retour de la
guerre de haute intensité sur notre
continent et enfin elle a nécessité
aussi et bien de comprendre comment
fonctionne notre démocratie et de créer
ces rencontres si précieuses avec les
élus nationaux que vous êtes où les élus
locaux pour rappeler que la démocratie
est une cause qui nous est bien chère et
que la citoyenneté et le civisme et bien
ça s'apprend ça s'apprend tout au long
de la vie bien sûr mais ça s'apprend au
plus jeune âge d'abord nous avons un
certain nombre de jeunes qui
s'abstiennent ou ne prennent plus
peut-être suffisamment acte de
l'importance de l'expression
démocratique ou de la relation avec avec
nos institutions c'était c'est tout
l'idée évidemment du service universelle
alors il est toujours composé de deux
phases le séjour de cohésion et d'une
mission d'intérêt général qu'avocation à
faire découvrir aussi et bien
l'importance et le pouvoir d'Achille de
chaque jeune au sein de d'une
collectivité au sein d'une association
ou au sein de nos sapeurs-pompiers au
sein des de nos gendarmerie mais en tout
cas au sein des acteurs du quotidien
il poursuit son développement
soit avec une phase d'engagement plus
longue que la phase 3 qui peut prendre
la forme d'un engagement dans nos
réserves réserve civiles ou militaires
je pense à la raison de l'éducation
nationale à la réserve les réserves de
nos armées ou au sein du service civique
que j'aurai l'occasion de redévelopper
poursuivre son engagement puisque c'est
et son déploiement puisque c'est la
demande du Président de la République
demande une augmentation budgétaire de
30 millions cette année pour arriver à
un budget de 140 millions mais surtout
surtout c'est qu'elle va être le SMU de
demain soit nous il y a deux hypothèses
qui sont étudiées soit effectivement ça
intègre le temps scolaire et donc ça
devient un temps d'application de
l'éducation civique et morale et donc
une mise en œuvre une mise pratique d'un
parcours de citoyenneté et donc comment
on le généralise en l'intégrant
pleinement dans les référentiels de
compétences
scolaire et donc ça s'adresserait
principalement à des jeunes de seconde
ou de première année de CAP soit on va
aller chercher effectivement encore plus
d'attractivité on lève des freins qui
aujourd'hui sont réels je pense aux
jeunes qui sont en lycée par exemple
professionnel pour qui le séjour de
cohésion tombent pendant leur stage
professionnel ou les lycées agricoles ou
pareil il y a des conflicts de
calendrier pour cela nous développons
d'autres séjours des séjours en dehors
de ces temps qui sont des temps
particuliers pour les jeunes en lycée
pro et en lycée agricole mais également
pour des jeunes qui après une
présentation très ambitieuse nous dit
enfin me disent en regardant les yeux
mais madame moi je travaille l'été et
donc je ne peux pas faire un séjour de
cohésion alors même que je suis engagée
lever ses freins c'est le rendre aussi
plus accessible un évidemment un maximum
de jeunes l'enveloppe alloué cette année
c'est pour poursuivre un développement
et un déploiement pour 64 64 000 jeunes
ce sont les enjeux de cette année en
particulier amplifié aussi le plan
mentorat il a été lancé le 1er mars 2021
avec un objectif de développer un réseau
une conscience de l'autre et un
accompagnement par des pères d'abord
appuyer sur le plan Agen une solution le
plan à jeunes Inventor et porté par un
budget de 27 millions d'euros et c'est
le la mobilisation d'étudiants de
professionnels mais aussi de jeunes
retraités c'est aussi la force du lien
et le témoignage de ces pairs je pense à
quelques associations chemin d'avenir
par exemple qui accompagne des jeunes
ruraux vers les grandes écoles par le
témoignage ou encore article 1 Télémaque
et si je commence à les citer évidemment
c'est toujours le risque le risque de la
limite mais ce qui était intéressant
c'est aujourd'hui le collectif mentorat
qui se réunit et qui par les actions
communes créées de la reine innovation
territoriale mon ministère porte une
attention particulière au soutien des
colonies de vacances également
parce que ce sont les principaux acteurs
de ce renouveau du lien des séjours
connaissent une baisse de fréquentation
depuis une dizaine d'années et le nombre
de départ aujourd'hui de mineurs se
stabilise depuis 2018-2019 en 2021 c'est
plus de 900000 enfants et adolescents
qui ont été pris en charge dans plus de
33000 séjours avec hébergement
c'est en s'étendre colonie sont des
temps où on apprend aussi à vivre en
collectivité en commun et ils sont
absolument essentiels d'où le soutien à
vacances apprenantes plus largement
développer le service civique c'est
d'ailleurs le Sénat qui dansa grande
sagesse en 2010 avait porté le
développement du service civique et qui
aujourd'hui touche plus de 600
000 jeunes qui ont qui font le choix de
s'engager
nous sommes aujourd'hui à plus de 145
000 jeunes qui ont effectué un service
civique en 2021 la vocation c'est qu'en
2022 ce soit stabilisée vous me posiez
monsieur le Président la question sur le
plan de relance qui du coup n'est
évidemment pas renouvelé pour autant le
budget du service civique continue
d'augmenter avec 20 millions d'euros
supplémentaires cette année parce que sa
dynamique est là et en même temps on a
un marché du travail qui est plus
favorable ma vraie ma vraie crainte et
là où je suis extrêmement vigilante
c'est qu'il n'est pas de substitution à
l'emploi et que le service civique reste
en réalité intendant indemniser bien sûr
c'est indemnisation a été augmentée en
contenu de l'inflation et elle est
soutenue pour les plus pour les familles
en tout cas les jeunes les plus en
difficulté par une aide supplémentaire
sociale de 100 euros
ce qui est certain c'est que et c'était
un des enjeux c'est comment on fait pour
que le service civique irrigue
l'ensemble de nos territoires et que ce
ne soit pas réservé aux territoires les
plus urbains ou les plus denses et donc
pour cela nous travaillons avec les
collectivités pour que un certain nombre
de services civiques soient portés par
des intercommunalités quand les communes
sont plus sont à taille plus petite ou
ne peuvent pas l'accueillir en tant que
tel soutenu parfois par des VTA qui
permettent le développement et le
déploiement sur sur certaines
intercommunalités en complémentarité
évidemment mon ministère soutient
l'éducation populaire de façon
préliminaire à nos échanges voilà
quelques éléments pour être concises
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs les enjeux forts qui sont
ceux de cette année toujours accompagner
la jeunesse verso de l'émancipation
avoir une ambition forte pour développer
la force morale de notre de notre
jeunesse dans un moment où les défis
sont multiples la culture de
l'engagement toujours et de renforcer
une cohésion nationale qui est plus que
jamais bousculée je ne reviendrai pas
sur les sur les différents les les
attentes à la liste en particulier dans
dans les lycées suite à une voilà des
offensives sur les réseaux sociaux mais
plus que jamais nous avons besoin de
développer cette culture de l'engagement
et de la développer sur l'ensemble des
territoires donc d'apporter des réponses
spécifiques voilà président de manière
concise les quelques éléments
préliminaires merci madame la secrétaire
d'État et sans plus tarder je donne la
parole à Madame
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis cher Jean-Bernard
manier mesdames les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs madame la ministre chère
Sarah je suis ravie de vous présenter
cet après-midi la partie vie associative
de cette mission sport jeunesse et via
associative aux côtés de ma collègue la
secrétaire d'État Sarah lairi j'en
profite si vous me le permettez pour
saluer la très bonne gestion financière
des crédits de la vie associatif par ma
prédécesseur qui me permet d'arriver
avec des finances saines dans ce
ministère et je veux commencer par
rappeler en quelques chiffres en
introduction le fait que nous avons en
France 20 millions de bénévoles soient
environ un Français sur trois et 1,5
millions d'associations qui œuvrent au
quotidien pour des causes killer sont
chères et toutes et tous ici du fait de
vos expériences bien évidemment d'élus
et d'élus locaux vous connaissez les
visages et les actions de ces mais de
ces hommes bénévoles dans vos
territoires qui donnent ce que nous
avons tous de plus précieux c'est à dire
notre temps ce sont je crois les poumons
de la vie démocratique et une formidable
école de la citoyenneté par le culture
du dialogue et du compromis qu'il faut
toujours avoir au sein d'une association
c'est l'apprentissage du vivant ensemble
et du travail en groupe et cependant
c'est vrai que ce secteur connaît et
traverse une crise de l'engagement selon
d'élitement qui s'est accéléré à cause
de l'épisode du covid et bien nous
tâcherons de poursuivre le travail pour
l'inverser c'est tout le sens de la
feuille de route qui m'a été fixée par
la première ministre dans la continuité
des actions conduites par ma
prédécesseur en articulant notre vision
autour de deux axes que nous partageons
avec les acteurs puisqu'ils ont été
construits avec ces acteurs un
simplification et de valorisation qui se
traduisent de la manière suivante sur le
volet simplification d'abord
si je souhaitais le prendre sous un
manque technique si j'ose dire je vous
dirais que la ligne fonctionnement est
numérique de la vie associative connaît
un doublement de ces crédits en 2023 par
rapport à l'année précédente et que nous
avons choisi de le faire passer de
757000 à 1,5 millions alors cela est
vrai mais qu'est-ce que ça signifie
concrètement ça signifie que nous
voulons vraiment mettre une priorité sur
le fait de faciliter la vie des
associations et de doter l'état d'une
meilleure grille de lecture de la vie
associative territoire par territoire
parmi les politiques publiques financées
nous trouvons donc des dispositifs
complémentaires le contasso qui est en
fonctionnement depuis le précédent
quinquennat qui est un outil numérique
qui offre la possibilité aux
associations de centraliser leurs
informations de nombreux renseignements
du quotidien des démarches
administratives des demandes de
subvention peuvent aussi passer par ce
biais c'est l'idée générale est vraiment
simple c'est la ligne conductrice du
dites-le nous une fois vis-à-vis de ces
associations donc c'est une une
simplification puisqu'en plus de
dématérialisation nous limitons aussi
les doubles saisies à terme l'objectif
c'est d'en faire un vrai guichet unique
de la vie associative pour permettre de
réduire le temps administratif de le
transformer en cœur de métier du temps
associatif si j'ose ce terme et surtout
de lever la charge mentale finalement du
dirigeant associatif comme du bénévole
ensuite nous finançons donc le projet
data asso c'est une véritable banque de
données de la vie associative son but
c'est d'obtenir des données pour
renseigner la puissance publique sur la
vitalité de la vie associative d'un
territoire mais aussi de faire connaître
le tissu associatif local aux habitants
pour encourager et dynamiser et bien
c'est volonté d'engagement pour cela une
carte interactive est disponible sur le
site un travail de déclinaison au niveau
des organes publics territoriaux est à
l'oeuvre pour qu'elle puisse là aussi
valoriser les associations de leur
territoire enfin data subvention si la
simplification est un enjeu pour les
associations je crois que c'est aussi un
enjeu pour l'État ainsi cette interface
interministérielle développée par une
start-up d'État doit améliorer la
lisibilité des subventions versées aux
associations les services qui reçoivent
des demandes et attributs les
subventions aux associations accède aux
informations déjà disponibles sur ces
associations donner administratives
subventions déjà versées subventions au
cours d'instruction l'idée c'est
vraiment de pouvoir faciliter leur
analyse gagner là aussi du temps
administratif mais côté état évitez de
multiplier les allers-retours en
demandant plusieurs fois le même
justificatif et ainsi éclairer la prise
de décision je pense que c'est
fondamental parce que je veux vraiment
construire un pacte de confiance entre
les services de l'État et les
associations et j'ai l'occasion d'être
ministre secrétaire d'État dans d'autres
dans d'autres ministères précédemment et
j'ai vu à quel point année après année
on a tendance à redemander les mêmes
informations aux associations alors
qu'en réalité en 7 ans plus financer des
associations dont bien évidemment
l'objectif et la raison d'être n'a pas
varié d'une année sur l'autre je pense à
des associations qui existaient déjà
depuis 10 ans qui existeront
probablement encore dans les 10
prochaines années et auxquelles nous
n'avons pas besoin de redemander sans
cesse leurs raisons d'être leurs
objectifs leur effectifs etc autre ligne
alimentant les dynamiques de
simplification animation de la vie
associative et les centres de ressources
et d'information des bénévoles elle
connaît là aussi une augmentation de ces
crédits qui porte le total à environ 3
millions d'euros principalement
concentré d'ailleurs sur le financement
de guides d'assaut c'est une très forte
demande de la part du secteur associatif
l'idée ici c'est de faire en sorte que
les associations d'un département quand
elles cherchent une information puisse
trouver l'information en proximité au
plus près d'elle-même en tapant à la
bonne porte donc pour cela guide
d'assaut par l'intermédiaire du
mouvement associatif et du délégué
départemental à la vie associative
mettent en réseau l'ensemble des
structures accompagne les associations
pour les orienter dans leur démarche et
dans leur projet dans une logique
vraiment de parcours et d'accompagnement
il est déjà présent dans trois régions
Centre Val de Loire nouvelle Aquitaine
aux deux France il s'étendra à trois
autres régions Bretagne Normandie et
Pays de la Loire chersara pour l'année à
venir et avec l'objectif de s'étendre à
l'ensemble du territoire pour 2024 vous
l'avez compris comme je le disais nous
voulons vraiment travailler à tisser ce
pacte de confiance avec les associations
fluidifier encore plus leurs relations
avec l'État et leur permettre de
s'épanouir là où est leur vocation c'est
à dire en créant du lien sur le terrain
c'est aussi indirectement une politique
d'attractivité des bénévoles et
d'attractivité des salariés dans les
associations nous avons reçu beaucoup
témoignages de bénévoles qui s'engagent
dans des associations et qui finalement
s'en vont au bout de quelques temps
parce que elle n'était pas venue pour
remplir de la paperasse pendant
plusieurs heures par jour ou par semaine
et donc en simplifiant ce volet
administratif nous travaillons aussi
indirectement à fidéliser et à attirer
de nouveaux bénévoles et singulièrement
dans les jeunes générations le deuxième
axe sur le volet valorisation soutien je
reviendrai dans un premier temps sur le
fdva que vous connaissez bien le fond de
développement de la vie associative vous
en connaissez toutes et tous
l'importance dans vos départements et je
ne doute pas qu'il y aura des questions
et des échanges sur ce sujet dans notre
temps d'échanges c'est ça reste la
principale source de soutien à la vie
associative locale et c'est un fond je
veux le dire qui a permis de financer
12000 actions donc 80% dans des petites
associations son montant pour l'année à
venir et constant par rapport à l'année
2022 avec 50 millions d'euros et une
ventilation semblable puisque il nous
est apparu sur la précédente année cette
ventilation était pertinente et elle se
décompose donc de la manière suivante 8
millions pour la la formation des
bénévoles plus de 160
000 de nos concitoyens ont pu d'ailleurs
en bénéficier au cours de cette année 25
millions pour le fonctionnement à
l'innovation qui a permis d'ailleurs
déjà d'accompagner 10000 associations
dans leurs projets d'évolution et de
croissance 17 millions pour le fond de
concours participation à financière
privée ou public au financement d'action
en faveur de la vie associative
autrement aussi appelée la cote-part sur
les comptes inactifs ensuite nous
retrouvons le compte d'engagement
citoyen il s'agit donc d'un dispositif
je crois essentiel puisqu'il rentre dans
les logiques portées par le gouvernement
depuis 2017 c'est-à-dire la formation
tout au long de la vie et l'objectif de
pleine emploi il s'agit de permettre de
valoriser l'engagement au crédit sur le
CPF en justifiant d'heures de bénévolat
elle-même validée par un dirigeant de
l'association à noter que par exemple le
ministère de l'Intérieur a signé le 3
novembre dernier un décret permettant
aux 200 000 sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
de notre pays de faire valoir leur
engagement via le CEC dans le champ de
la reconnaissance et de la valorisation
des diplômes je veux ici aborder la
question de la VAE de la valorisation et
de la validation des acquis de
l'expérience vous savez que le
gouvernement porte avec le mystère du
travail et mes collègues Olivier dusoft
et Carole Grandjean réforme globale de
la VAE dans le but de la simplifier et
de la rendre plus large et bien nous
voulons un focus c'est la première
ministre m'a demandé de travailler
spécifiquement sur le sujet de la VAE
bénévole trop peu de bénévoles savent
qu'ils peuvent faire valoir leurs acquis
de l'expérience du bénévolat pour le
transformer en diplôme et donc notre mot
d'ordre c'est de dire transformer votre
expérience de bénévolat en diplôme tout
simplement nous travaillons à cet égard
à la création d'une plateforme qui
permettra très simplement et facilement
de savoir à quel diplôme en tant que
bénévole on peut avoir accès et je veux
aussi qu'on puisse obtenir des
certifications quand on a par exemple
exercé la tâche de trésorerie d'une
associations organisée des événements ou
travailler dans le champ sanitaire et
social c'est un lien fort entre
l'engagement bénévole et la sphère
professionnelle je voudrais vraiment le
renforcer d'abord je crois que ça permet
de venir valoriser un temps donné pour
l'intérêt général on sait quand on est
bénévole c'est pas toujours facile et
reconnu auprès de nos proches auprès de
notre famille que de dire qu'on va
passer du temps qu'on n'est pas obligé
de donner et qu'on va ressortir le
dimanche après-midi ressortir le soir
pour s'engager au service de l'intérêt
général ce diplôme il vient d'une
certaine manière valoriser cela de façon
très positive et puis c'est aussi une
manière de s'inscrire dans l'objectif
pleine emploi voulu par le Président de
la République et le ministre du travail
et du plein emploi pour dire que parfois
quand on souhaite se reconvertir et bien
on peut aussi passer par le biais de la
VAE après un passage de bénévoles dans
une association je pense également que
ça répond à la quête de sens qu'on
évoque très souvent des salariés et
aussi à l'attrait plus de plus en plus
fort des employeurs pour ce type de
compétences enfin pour récolter les
bonnes pratiques mais aussi les
difficultés des bénévoles sur le terrain
et pour alimenter notre co-construction
de politique publique j'ai lancé en
octobre dernier dans l'Orne le Tour de
France du bénévolat l'idée c'est de
réunir à chaque fois sur une
demi-journée dans chaque département des
associations qui agissent dans des
champs très différents cultures sport
environnement égalité des chances et des
droits sanitaires et sociales etc au
sein d'un même département et d'animer
un atelier autour de quatre thématiques
la gouvernance la valorisation de
l'engagement la formation des bénévoles
et la coopération avec les associations
ces déplacements ils sont aussi
l'occasion de mettre en avant les
bénévoles particulièrement impliqués
depuis des années en leur décernant des
médailles je tiens à dire au
parlementaire au sénateur et au
sénatrice ici présent que je tiens à
votre disposition si vous le souhaitez
des médailles également du bénévolat si
vous souhaitez vous même en discerner
dans vos circonscriptions à des
bénévoles particulièrement t’engagé
c'est une opération qui aura lieu sur
l'ensemble du territoire hexagonal comme
ultramarin je serais très heureuse aussi
de répondre à vos invitations si vous le
souhaitez pour venir et tout ce travail
s'inscrit dans cet objectif de faire en
sorte que l'engagement bénévole est plus
largement la vie associative
Eric véritablement notre société avec
ces deux grands objectifs de simplifier
de valoriser vous l'aurez compris
mesdames laissées natrices et messieurs
les sénateurs l'état un regard attentif
aux difficultés que connaît le monde
associatif nous les méconnons pas et au
contraire nous voulons aller à leur
rencontre pour y apporter des réponses
et nous menons pour cela les chantiers
nécessaires aux côtés de ces acteurs
structurants et important de nos
territoires qui sont aussi des vecteurs
de liens social de l'intérêt général
pour leur permettre de toujours mieux
exercer leur raison d'être c'est à dire
cet intérêt général justement je vous
remercie
merci mesdames la ministre première
question de notre rapporteur Jacques
Bernard manié qui a noté avec beaucoup
d'intérêt ce que vous avez dit sur les
colonies de vacances merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et c'est un état
merci pour les présentations que vous
nous avez faites de ce budget 163 qui
représente
837 millions d'euros vous l'avez rappelé
mais
qui est un budget essentiellement
à destination du service civique avec
518 millions d'euros et service national
universel 140 millions d'euros donc déjà
658 millions sur 304 88837 il ne reste
pas beaucoup pour le reste des actions
de la vie associative au déjeunesse que
ces dispositifs là en tout cas
madame la secrétaire des tâches chargée
donc de la vie associative j'ai bien
entendu votre volonté
d'impact de confiance avec les
associations j'espère qu'il n'y avait
pas de pacte de défiance jusqu'à
maintenant c'est parce que vous n'avez
plus ressentir pour avoir auditionné
beaucoup de têtes de réseau du monde
associatif de ce pays je pense que les
associations sont dans l'attente et
toujours prête à
participer aux actions qui sont initiées
par par le gouvernement par les
gouvernement quels qu'ils soient par les
gouvernements successifs en faveur du
monde associatif et de la vie citoyenne
vous l'avez rappelé toutes les deux
en tout cas
pour ce qui me concerne je voudrais
noter simplement vous avez parlé du
compte d'engagement citoyen à Madame là
c'est un état mais il est en diminution
considérable puisqu'on passe de 15
millions d'euros en 2022 à 6 millions
d'euros dans le projet de budget alors
est-ce que cela signifierait que ce
dispositif ne fonctionne pas ou est-ce
que il aurait besoin de VOUS soins pour
qu'ils comprennent mieux qu'il soit
mieux connus des bénévoles qui devraient
être bénéficiaires
et puis vous avez parlé du fond de
développement de la vie associative
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet important
qui a été avec deux grandes branches
pour la formation des bénévoles et pour
l'aide au fonctionnement des
associations et qui a été alimenté avec
les 25 millions de la réservoir
alimentaire on se plaît à le rappeler
parce que en 2017 on nous a amputé de
quelque chose dont on se servait non pas
pour faire de la du clientélisme mais
pour essayer de faire d'aider à la fois
nos associations et nos petites
collectivités en tout cas maintenant
c'est du passé et puis il y a aussi
quelque chose d'important qui alimente
ce DVA ce sont les fonds inactifs des
comptes bancaires qui ont enfin pu être
versés 17 millions et demi cette année
prévu là aussi je vous pose des
questions est-ce qu'il ne serait pas bon
d'essayer d'augmenter la quote-part qui
est actuellement de 20% de ses comptes
et lorsqu'on avait beaucoup débattu pour
essayer d'obtenir un peu d'argent pour
le monde associatif enfin on avait
obtenu 20% mais comme ce sont souvent
des comptes associatifs est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas obtenir une quote-part un
peu plus importante qui viendrait
abonder le fdva donc vous avez parlé et
qui est un outil important pour la
formation et aussi pour les petites
associations
madame le traiter d'État a changé de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel vous nous avez alors je vais
parler de suite du service national
universel puisque vous nous en avez
parlé le bilan 2022 n'est pas bon vous
l'avez dit vous-même vous le savez 50000
prévus 110 millions de budget 32 000
réalisés
quelle confusion en tirez-vous vous
allez nous le dire parce que c'est quand
même un échec sur une année sur laquelle
on comptait voir un développement assez
impressionnant puisque vous aviez prévu
le double 50 000 personnes 50000 jeunes
et puis ensuite les 110 millions est-ce
qu'ils ont été consommés parce que si on
prévoit 110 millions pour 50000 est-ce
qu'on dépense 110 millions pour 32000
auquel cas ça fait cher le service
national universel
par rapport aux prévisions 2023 que vous
avez présenté 140 millions cette année
soit 30 millions de plus 64
000 jeunes prévus soit le doublement de
ce qui est réalisé cette année
ça nous fait ça nous inquiète un peu
préoccupe de savoir quand on voit le
résultat qui a pu y avoir dans les
années précédentes même si les années
covides effectivement étaient
pénalisantes mais tout cela est le
budget qui est attribué à ce sinus fait
pas lire le reste du monde associatif
peut vous l'assurer pour l'avoir
constaté lors des auditions qu'on a pu
mener ici avec mes collègues sénateurs
et ses actrices
alors madame est-ce que c'est un état
est-ce qu'il ne serait pas bon en 2023
de faire un point sur ce service
national universel est-ce que on
pourrait enfin avoir un débat
parlementaire là dessus et puis se dire
que ce sera peut-être difficile de le
généraliser à la 800000 jeunes pour des
raisons financières mais aussi pour des
raisons d'adhésion tout simplement donc
je pense que nous sommes au milieu du
gué et je pense que vous le savez il va
falloir maintenant essayer de trouver
une solution
savoir si on continue ou si on arrête
j'espère je dis pas dit que j'espère
qu'on arrête mais j'espère qu'on est le
débat pour savoir
et puis nous prêtons pas aussi revoir un
parcours citoyen qui commence à l'école
élémentaire alors vous avez parlé des
colonies de vacances vous savez que me
sont chers et on vous proposer l'année
dernière un amendement je l'ai pas
refait cette année c'est pas la peine on
ne va pas recommencer les choses qui ne
marchent pas de soutenir un passe colo
pour que
les classes moyennes puissent revenir
encore une des vacances parce que ça
coûte cher mais aussi ça peut être
incitatif parce que vous savez bien
comme moi qu'un Colomb peut devenir un
moniteur un animateur et que le BAFA
donc vous parlez sur lequel vous avez
fait des efforts cette année je le
reconnais pourrait faire partie d'un
parcours qui ferait que colo BAFA
service civique serait un tout qui
pourrait alors peut-être s'appeler
service national universel cette fois-ci
parce qu'il pourrait finir par conserver
tous les jeunes à un coût qui serait
certainement moindre que celui qu'on
envisage avec ce séjour de 15 jours de
séjour de cohésion qui nous paraît bien
difficile de mettre en place pour tous
les jeunes de ce pays et enfin je dirais
un mot sur le service civique et
l'augmente cette année effectivement de
4% que cette inférieur à l'inflation qui
sera enregistrée en C1 2023 donc
réellement il stagne pourtant je pense
c'est un dispositif qui est très utile
qui est pertinent pour tous les jeunes
qu'il a sans volontaire et qui sont
nombreux ils sont plus nombreux que ce
que l'on peut en retenir voilà des
questions que je voulais vous poser
mesdames
non on répond d'abord à celle du
rapporteur et après on prendra les
autres en série je vous en prie
merci pardon j'ai perdu l'habitude en
termes de Modus opérandit mais je suis
ravie de les retrouver d'abord pour
répondre sur le rapporteur sur le sujet
du pack de conscience vous avez tout à
fait raison de me poser la question et
je suis ravie d'éclairer je considère
pas qu'il y avait jusqu'à présent un
pack de défiance pas du tout en revanche
en tout cas pas de la part de l'État en
revanche c'est vrai que je le dis j'ai
été moi-même 10 ans présidente d'un
réseau associatif j'ai été lu local j'ai
eu la charge pour le gouvernement des
associations dans le champ de l'égalité
fameux et de la lutte contre les
discriminations ensuite dans le champ de
la laïcité de la citoyenneté désormais
dans le champ plus large de la vie
associative et j'observe que
effectivement les associations sont
noyées sous l'administratif moi j'adore
mon pays je suis très patriote et je
suis infiniment fière d'être française
néanmoins on a quand même une passion
française pour la paperasse qui est réel
qui existe et moi tous les jours j'ai
des associations qui me montrent à quel
point on leur demande des comptes sur
des choses pour lesquelles on leur a
déjà demandé des comptes six mois il y a
un an etc quand je parle de pack de
confiance peut-être pour rentrer un
petit peu plus dans le détail je parle
également de la manière dont on attribue
les subventions on est très
précautionneux avec l'argent public et
moi je me vante d'être très prudente et
de ne pas donner facilement de l'argent
public néanmoins je pense que on
pourrait gagner aussi à privilégier et
c'est un retour qui nous a beaucoup été
fait par des associations mais aussi par
des élus les subventions de
fonctionnement sur les fonctions sur les
subventions d'appel à projets et les
subventions de plus long terme ou les
CPO qui permettent aux associations
d'avoir un peu de visibilité de
s'organiser et de porter leurs propres
projets plutôt qu'être simplement mise
dans la situation d'être opérateur de
service public et de faire finalement la
mise en oeuvre de la politique publique
décidé par le gouvernement même si c'est
très bien par ailleurs c'est ça que je
veux dire par ce pack de confiance c'est
à dire de trouver la manière d'avoir un
engagement véritablement réciproque en
la matière je vais vous donner un
exemple également il y a des obligations
pour certaines association au regard de
la transparence dans leur relation avec
les élus moi je ne confonds pas une
association et un cabinet de lobbying un
cabinet de lobbying il sert des intérêts
privés et c'est normal qu'il ait un
travail de transparence très méticuleux
des comptes rendus à faire et des
déclarations à faire quand il rencontre
des élus pour servir ses intérêts en
revanche une association qui va défendre
la préservation des espaces naturels du
Finistère ou la protection des femmes
face aux violences conjugales ou tout
autre type d'associations que vous
connaissez par cœur et depuis fort
longtemps j'estime que elle ne
rencontrent pas un élu pour servir son
intérêt privé mais pour servir l'intérêt
général et qu'on pourrait donc dans ce
cadre par exemple alléger les formalités
qui lui sont demandés donc c'est un
travail que nous un chantier que nous
allons mettre en place que de travailler
sur cette simplification avec des
consultations et des écoutes des
auditions d'association et des ateliers
pour arriver à trouver des solutions qui
à la me permet de trouver un point
d'équilibre encore plus poussé entre la
conscience qu'on peut manifester
concrètement aux associations et le
soutien qu'on crée dans la durée d'une
part et d'autre part le fait pour ces
associations de souscrire naturellement
un certain nombre de de compte-rendus de
ce qui a été fait avec de l'argent
public mais je pense que là aussi on
peut vraiment s'amplifier les choses et
mettre la transparence au bon endroit
mais ça c'est un vaste débat public de
qu'est-ce que la transparence et où
est-ce qu'on doit mettre la transparence
mais moi je considère que une
association est tout à fait dans son
rôle quand elle rencontre des élus et
qu'on peut peut-être sortir d'une aire
un peu de soupçons à demander de rendre
des comptes sur à peu près tous les
faits et gestes d'une association à cet
égard et donc c'est le travail que nous
allons tâcher de mettre en place parce
que c'est vraiment ce que nous ont dit
les associations elle nous disent à
chaque fois mais faites-nous confiance
nous savons faire nous existons depuis
longtemps nous sommes des associations
reconnues et nous avons besoin d'avoir
de la conscience et de la vision sur le
long terme y compris sur ce que
j'évoquais sur les subventions et je
crois que là aussi c'est extrêmement
important sur le compte d'engagement
citoyen vous avez parfaitement raison
monsieur le rapporteur sur votre analyse
budgétaire du budget écoulé c'est vrai
qu'on a une sous-exécution du budget du
compte d'engagement citoyen c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin de le faire encore plus
connaître alors il y a un travail qui a
été initié à cet égard mais on doit
pouvoir encore plus faire de la
pédagogie en direction des acteurs
concernés sur sur ce contrat
d'engagement rappeler qu'on peut
reconnaître et valoriser et valoriser
par ton engagement en permettant
d'acquérir ces droits à la formation
inscrits sur le CPF 240 euros par an
avec une limite de 720 euros c'est vrai
qu'il y a des conditions qui existent à
l'heure actuelle donc on doit pouvoir
aussi peut-être à un moment dans le
cadre de ces consultations et ce Tour de
France avec les associations regarder si
ces conditions sont pertinentes mais les
conditions à l'heure actuelle c'est que
l'association doit avoir au moins trois
ans qu'il faut être bénévole depuis au
moins un an justifiée de 200 heures 100
heures dans la même association et on
sait que notamment les jeunes
générations ont tendance à aller d'une
association à l'autre donc c'est une une
condition de plus il y a une possibilité
néanmoins des saisons voire 15 pour les
apprentis et qui est je le disais
élargir récemment aux pompiers et aux
mètres de stage et donc l'idée c'est
justement pour ça que ça avait été
élargi au sapeurs-pompiers volontaire
lors du précédent quinquennat et de
faire en sorte que le décret qui avait
été publié le 5 novembre dernier vise à
simplifier justement cette procédure
pour que les bénévoles éligibles
s'inscrivent davantage donc là ce sera
tout un travail à faire de notre côté
pour aller justement à leur rencontre et
aller travailler avec eux c'est le sens
aussi du Tour de France du bénévolat moi
je veux vous dire vraiment que c'est un
dispositif qui fonctionne je défends le
dispositif mais vraiment qui gagne à
être connu et pour cette année si on
veut faire un budget qui soit pas
insensé et qui correspondent vraiment
aux objectifs réalisables et tangibles
de l'année le budget me semble
dimensionner par rapport à ce qu'on peut
viser et notamment qui peut être aussi
en premier pas vis-à-vis de la question
de la VAE bénévole en ce qui concerne le
fond de développement de la vie
associative oui vous avez tout à fait
raison de rappeler son historique et je
sais que il est cher au parlementaire si
je si je puis dire le fond se divise en
3 il y a le oui pardon pour le
l'utilisation du champ lexical financier
le fdva bénévole pour la formation à 8
millions le fdva fonctionnement
innovation à 25 millions et depuis 2020
la quote-part sur les comptes bancaires
inactifs alors l'enveloppe est discuté
au niveau départemental comme vous le
savez avec une partie égale pour tous
les départements et une part variable
sur les critères de GF et vitalité
associatives territoire par territoire
mais sur les chiffres généraux et sur le
financement la ligne budgétaire du fdva
elle reste dans un montant constant à 33
millions en 2022 en 2023 également et à
ce stade il me semble que c'est là aussi
un budget qui correspond
aux réalités en termes de portage
politique je veux dire que c'est à mon
humble avis un dispositif qui se déploie
correctement avec l'ensemble des
territoires et qui touche sa cible en
tout cas puisqu'on a une majorité de
petites associations si je puis dire
petite entre guillemets qui en sont au
bénéficiaires ou d'associations locales
territoriales et c'est vraiment dans cet
état d'esprit que le fdva avait été créé
dans les conditions que vous avez
rappelé donc moi j'ai plutôt le
sentiment si je regarde les choses
objectivement que jusqu'à présent il a
réussi à atteindre sa cible et qu'on a
là aussi un travail pour le faire
connaître j'observe que de manière
générale sur le sujet des subventions on
a beaucoup d'associations qui pourraient
prétendre à subvention ou à financement
public d'une manière ou d'une autre et
qui ne et qui ne répondent pas en
réalité parce que ça prend du temps
c'est ce que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
parce que les procédures sont lourdes ou
parfois même parce qu'elles ne le savent
pas je rencontrais beaucoup
d'associations non financées ni par
l'État ni par les collectivités quand je
leur pose la question elle me pas bon on
peut mais comment on fait ça voilà donc
ça fait partie aussi du travail qu'on va
essayer de faire au niveau local pour
aller dire à ces petites entre
guillemets associations qui ont pas de
permanent pour remplir ces documents
qu'elles peuvent aussi être éligibles à
ce type de financement j'espère avoir
répondu à ces questions
sur le rapporteur sur les questions que
vous posez concernant et le service
civique et le service station universel
c'est clair on est à un moment d'homme
quand j'ai on est un momentum on est à
un moment où on doit décider de quelle
va être l'avenir du service national
universel mais ce que je vois c'est
peut-être que l'objectif quantitatif il
est ambitieux c'est clair il était
ambitieux en 2019 c'était 2000 jeunes en
2020 on a eu la covid en 2021 on a fait
15000 jeunes en 2022 plus de 32000
chaque année en double et donc si vous
regardez la courbe cette année en
réalité l'objectif c'est de doubler
l'année précédente donc sur ces
objectifs là c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
atteint mais bon moi ma course n'est pas
une course à l'échalote au nombre pour
être tout à fait sincère et honnête avec
vous ma question c'est comment on va
atteindre l'état final recherché
c'est-à-dire pourquoi on le fait dans le
fond et le SNU pour qu'on le fait dans
le fond c'est pour que un jeune de
trappe un jeune de Nantes et un jeune
d'Aurillac un moment se retrouve et
après une des choses qui sont
nécessaires à cette cohésion sociale et
cohésion nationale ça veut dire quoi
très concrètement c'est une première
mobilité c'est permettre à des jeunes
qui ne partent jamais de se retrouver à
des jeunes finalement de se détacher de
la de la présence des marques dans les
lycées en portant un uniforme et vivre
un temps de patriotisme c'est vrai
d'avoir accès à la aussi en réalité un
bilan de santé à un moment donné à un
instant T alors oui évidemment on a les
services de santé de l'école et dont on
connaît l'état bien sûr aujourd'hui mais
c'est aussi permettre à des jeunes de
découvrir le patrimoine culturel de leur
permettre de passer le PSC1 les gestes
qui sauvent de savoir réagir en cas de
catastrophe naturelle j'en parlais tout
à l'heure ce sont des apprentissages qui
ne sont aujourd'hui objectivement pas
fait au sein de de nos établissements
scolaires puisque ce n'est pas la
mission aujourd'hui il y a de la
sensibilisation il y a de l'éducation il
y a de l'information mais le Séni c'est
la mise en œuvre de tout cela avec un
objectif de cohésion nationale très
assumée
par contre là où là où je vous rejoins
c'est comment on fait aujourd'hui quand
on n'a pas atteint l'objectif
quantitatif de l'année dernière alors je
ne n'ai pas dépensé de l'argent plus
alors que le nombre était moins il y a
eu en Loire rectificative en loi de
finance rectificative un redéploiement
et je sais que ça va vous parler
directement au coeur j'aurais
déploiement a été fait à l'attention des
colos apprenants puisque l'objectif
commun entre les deux si vous me
permettez
l'argumentation un peu rapide c'est la
mobilité c'est la cohésion et donc le
redéploiement a été de plus de 24
millions d'euros je vous le fais je vous
le fais de mémoire mais quand on voit
aujourd'hui les défis de notre temps
plus que jamais nous avons besoin et il
reste à dans nos esprits de faire que
notre jeunesse elle se elle se sentent
elle se sentent unique elle est le goût
de l'engagement le goût de l'effort
peut-être aussi lever la peur et le
frein du départ de la maison un jeune
sur deux n'avait jamais pris le train
tout seul et en même temps de venir
corriger cette mixité sociale qui sais
pas encore parfaite au sein du SNU c'est
vrai on a beaucoup de d'enfants de
fonctionnaires on a beaucoup d'enfants
d'enseignants pour certains de corps en
uniformes même si ça s'améliore on est
passé d'un taux de nombre de jeunes qui
viennent des quartiers populaires de 4%
à plus de 7%. alors qu'au niveau
national on est à 9 les jeunes des
lycées professionnels on est passé de 14
à presque 17 mais on a 33% de nos jeunes
qui sont en formation professionnelle
moi ma mission réellement c'est de faire
que ce temps de séjour de cohésion ce ne
soit pas un totem que le parcours de
citoyenneté il s'inscrivent dès le début
et ça veut dire la reconnaissance de la
démocratie scolaire ça veut dire
l'engagement de contre le harcèlement ça
veut dire les jeunes sapeurs-pompiers ça
veut dire nos conseils municipaux jeunes
et finalement c'est comment construire
un parcours de citoyenneté et donc de
civisme tout au long de la vie préparant
finalement à ce grand moment de la
majorité à 18 ans
et puis on peut se dire les choses de
manière très claire nous avons besoin
dans notre pays et bien de conforter
notre culture de la protection civile
face aux nouvelles conséquences
climatiques mais aussi par rapport à
notre modèle de sécurité civile
aujourd'hui on connaît tous nos 10 on
connaît la part et l'engagement de nos
sapeurs-pompiers au volontaires c'est à
s'inscrit dans la continuité de
l'engagement de ma collègue Marlène
Schiappa sur la reconnaissance de leurs
engagements a posteriori lever des
freins l'accès au permis de conduire on
sait aujourd'hui que c'est un frein
essentiel à l'accès à l'emploi et pour
certains à l'accès même à la formation
professionnelle et donc l'ambition que
la mienne c'est de évidemment devant la
représentation nationale au-delà de
présenter l'évolution du référentiel de
compétences puisque le SMIC 2019 n'est
plus la SNI de 2022 de le présenter à la
représentation nationale sur le fond et
sur les projections et comme la rappeler
le président de la République dans son
discours à Toulon au moment de la
présentation de de la revue stratégique
il y aura de fait des arbitrages
proposés et battu évidemment au sein du
Sénat et de l'Assemblée nationale pour
l'avenir de ce service national
universel plus que jamais moi je crois
essentiel puisque neuf jeune sur 10 sont
satisfaits ou très satisfaits après
l'avoir après l'avoir vécu
le président de manière très concrète
aujourd'hui nous avons à l'étude de deux
hypothèses effectivement une hypothèse
de généralisation en s'inscrivant dans
le temps scolaire et donc en
renforcement de l'éducation civique et
morale et puis nous avons une deuxième
hypothèse qui est également à l'étude
qui est augmentée l'attractivité du
service national universel avec par
exemple le financement du bafal
financement du permis de conduire ou
encore la certification d'un certain
nombre de soft skills évidemment et la
première hypothèse et la deuxième sera
présentée à leur présentation nationale
pour choisir la voie en tout cas qui met
le plus en réponse à notre jeunesse
alors maintenant je vais prendre toutes
les questions elles achalke
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Mesdames les secrétaires d'État alors
nous interviendrons à devoir pour le
groupe les républicains je m'attacherai
à répondre enfin en tout cas à vos
questionnez sur le budget jeunesse et je
laisserai mon collègue Cédric Vial sur
la partie vie associative donc le budget
relatif à la jeunesse concerne
principalement finalement en fait les
actions en faveur de l'engagement des
jeunes notamment sur la question du
service civique et du déploiement du SNU
c'est donc sur ces deux dispositifs que
porteront mes questions je tiens au
préalable à saluer le travail qui a été
mené par notre rapporteur qui a fait
part aujourd'hui de plusieurs
interrogations et que nous partageons en
partie notamment concernant
effectivement le service national
universel et nous avions déjà émis ces
interrogations l'an dernier nous
examinons finalement le premier budget
jeunesse de ce mandat un budget qui
s'inscrit dans la droite ligne des
années précédentes et à ce titre je
tiens à nouveau à exprimer d'emblée un
regret celui finalement du manque de
lisibilité et de visibilité de la
politique jeunesse qui est menée par le
gouvernement dans son ensemble parce que
on voit bien la politique jeunesse qui
d'ailleurs avait été érigée en priorité
par le Président de la République elle
se retrouve éparpillée dans différentes
missions budgétaires sans que l'on
puisse finalement percevoir la cohérence
mais également la vision d'ensemble que
vous souhaitez pour les jeunes de notre
pays ceci étant dit il ressort de ce
budget finalement que l'on pourrait
appeler engagement des jeunes une hausse
des crédits augmentation effectivement
liée en très grande partie au
déploiement du SNU le budget alloué au
SNUI augmente à nouveau cette année avec
une augmentation de 30 millions d'euros
par rapport à 2022 nous assistons donc à
une augmentation du budget alors même
effectivement que les objectifs qui
avaient été fixés l'an dernier sont loin
d'avoir été atteint là où le du SMU pour
2022 degrés financer l'accueil de 50000
jeunes ce sont effectivement 32000
jeunes qui ont été concernés par le
dispositif soit 18000 jeunes de moins
mais on voit bien aussi au-delà en fait
des chiffres que sur même les objectifs
qui sont alloués
au SNU avec des missions qui sont très
très différentes il faudra pouvoir aussi
concentrer pour pouvoir avoir une
finalité et une réussite au bout donc
mes premières questions c'est comment
expliquer vous justement que le SNU
n'est pas rempli ses objectifs l'an
dernier malgré quand même les moyens
très importants qui avaient été mis en
oeuvre pouvez-vous nous dire quel a été
en 2022 le coûte effectif par jeune du
séjour de cohésion parce que je ne crois
qu'on n'a pas ce chiffre à l'heure
actuelle comment avez-vous fixé ce
nouvel objectif pour l'année à venir de
64000 donc j'ai entendu un doublement
par rapport à ce qui avait été réalisé
mais est-ce que c'est réaliste cette
année
notamment je crois qu'il était prévu
dans le recruter près de 9000 encadrants
est-ce que vous avez les capacités de
répondre à ce besoin et effectivement
par rapport à ce nouveau budget vous
comprendrez nos réserves de nouveau
puisqu'il était question de généraliser
effectivement le SNU là j'entends qu'il
y a deux voies différentes qui sont
possibles et qui sont sur la table mais
je rejoins monsieur le rapporteur sur la
nécessité d'avoir un débat au Parlement
sur le service national universel
d'autant plus que s'il y avait une
généralisation à une ensemble enfin une
classe d'âge dans son ensemble le coût
qui évalué qui est apparemment et la
fourchette basse serait quand même de
1,7 milliards d'euros donc voilà sur la
partie service national universel sur le
service civique je crois que nous sommes
tous salués ce dispositif notamment le
travail de l'Agence nationale du service
civique c'est qui rencontrent un réel
succès et qui d'ailleurs n'a cessé de
faire ses preuves depuis maintenant 12
ans l'augmentation des crédits pour ce
budget qui est à salué cette
augmentation elle est quand même à
relativiser puisque la moitié de la
hausse concerne la prise en compte de
l'augmentation du point d'adice
notamment alors après sur le fond même
de du service civique on le voit
notamment par un sondage odoxa qui a été
réalisé récemment
l'existence même du dispositif est connu
Paris eu les jeunes il a une image qui
est plutôt très positive mais on voit
bien en fait que beaucoup ne connaissent
pas à la fois les modalités du service
civique ces contours ça a duré sa
réalisation à la fois d'ailleurs dans le
secteur public et dans le secteur privé
donc on voit bien aussi la nécessité de
communiquer encore davantage et
notamment de pouvoir
faire connaître les bénéfices qu'un tel
dispositif pourrait avoir notamment sur
un parcours professionnel d'où ma
question comment constatez-vous
accroître justement sa valorisation et
peut-être une dernière question puisque
vous l'avez abordé madame la secrétaire
d'État dans votre intervention vous
savez qu'ici nous sommes
particulièrement sensibles au fait que
les jeunes puissent avoir accès au
service civiques dans tous les
territoires est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire davantage sur le développement
du service civique en milieu rural comme
il l'avait déjà été question lors de
l'examen du budget dernier je vous
remercie
Thomas dessus
merci monsieur le Président donc la
ministre et la heri au-delà du
quantitatif pour le SNU dans le bilan
est plus que mitigé ça a été dit je
crois que vous avez une vision du SMU un
peu abstraite on peut reprendre quelques
épisodes dont on a eu connaissance cette
année en juillet une vidéo à Strasbourg
monde 130 jeunes épuisé alignés dans la
cour d'un centre sénu pour faire du
pompe et du gainage plusieurs jeunes
sont en pleurs et se plaignent de la
douleur la vidéo a été filmée par des
encadrants responsables de la punition
le 13 juillet le Canard Enchaîné a
révélé que lors de la cérémonie du 18
juin 31 jeunes participants au SMU ont
fini aux urgences après avoir été laissé
en garde à vous en plein soleil en
pleine canicule le 2 août le compte
Twitter la police nationale du Bas-Rhin
vente l'organisation d'un stage de
monotage avec des jeunes du SNU atelier
dans lequel ils sont invités et à
immobiliser leurs camarades avec
l'utilisation de menottes réservée
notamment normalement aux forces de
l'ordre
alors c'est pas forcément des cas isolés
puisque pour moi les incarnent vraiment
l'identité du s&u à un moment qui se
veut républicain mais vider toute
substances et qui devient un espèce de
simulacre du service militaire dans le
pire de ces dérives le maniement des
armes en moins faux service et donc vrai
qu'apparisation de la jeunesse
mais le SNU n'est pas le seul outil de
caporisation de la société déployée par
le gouvernement et là je m'adressais à
Madame la Ministre Marielle
Marlène Schiappa excusez-moi vous venez
de parler de facilité la vie des
associations
il y a quelques mois la loi confortant
les principes de la République dit toi
séparatisme apportant instaurer le
contrat d'engagement républicain que les
associations doivent signer pour espérer
obtenir un agrément des subventions ou
des avantages fiscaux alors le résultat
est prévisible et le mouvement
associatif avaient déjà alerté au moment
de l'étude du texte en septembre dernier
le prof le préfet de Vienne a appelé à
retirer les subventions à l'association
écologiste alternatiba en raison de
l'organisation d'un atelier de
désobéissance civile les contrats
d'engagement républicains deviennent des
outils utilisés contre la liberté
associative la liberté d'expression et
pour mettre au pas les associations
militantes qui s'opposent à votre
politique on est loin de la lutte contre
le séparatisme islamiste
pourtant la vie la vitalité associative
et l'émancipation de la jeunesse ne sont
pas des menaces pour notre République
alors si nous sommes dans un momentum
pour le SNU profitons-en finissons-en
les crédits alloués au seinus 140
millions cette année avec un objectif de
1,5 milliards à terme serait mieux
utilisé dans le soutien à l'éducation
populaire dans les crédits sont pour la
deuxième année consécutive inférieurs à
ceux du s&u ce serait un signal
appréciable à toute notre société je
vous remercie
Cédric VIAL
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
collègue je suis désolé je vais devoir
vous laisser rapidement après ce que
j'insiste indépendant en hémicycle mais
je suis vrai vos réponses avec attention
en replay
très rapidement
moi je voudrais m'inscrire dans la
continuité de ce qu'a dit ma collègue et
les achalke pour vous dire qu'on a un
problème de lisibilité il y a un
problème de visibilité aussi bien avec
la politique jeunesse ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure qu'avec la politique de
devis associative
j'ai pas encore bien compris
l'organisation qui est la vôtre je vous
avais posé la question madame elle est
gris sur la plus-value que pouvait
apporter ou les conséquences
qu'apportaient votre attachement
également au ministère des armées même
chose pour Madame Schiappa on sait que
la vie associative c'est quelque chose
qui est organisé dans au sein de chaque
mission de chaque ministère
cette vision un peu interministérielle
que je pensais qu'on allait voir avec
l'organisation de votre ministère pour
l'instant elle reste encore très très
abstraite voir absente puisque chaque
ministère en tous les cas sauf vous avez
peut-être me contredire chaque ministère
aujourd'hui continue à organiser la
gestion et la ville de la vie
associative au sein de démission qui
gère et de ses missions
donc je vois pas forcément aujourd'hui
encore la plus-value qu'apporte cette
nouvelle cette nouvelle organisation
on pourrait parler aussi du fdva vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure je vais pas
revenir sur les débats ou mes collègues
importants aussi peut-être
tout à l'heure mais on a aussi la perte
de lisibilité puisque
on a des fonds alors c'est 8 millions
c'est pas c'est pas énorme mais on a des
fonds qui sont qui sont apportés sans
forcément qu'ils soient rattachés aux
missions de de la Golf et donc sans
qu'on sache forcément à quelle mission
et le concours et je vais dire si je
suis un peu provocateur sans forcément
mais ceux qui les attribuent le sachent
puisque ceux qui les attribuent
aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus des élus ce
sont ces la préfecture avec des services
de la préfecture qui sont pas forcément
les meilleures connaisseurs des
associations sur les territoires donc il
y a aussi une perte de visibilité et de
lisibilité je pourrais parler aussi
d'une perte de contrôle
vous avez abordé plusieurs sujets madame
madame Chiapas mais à chaque fois on est
on est sur l'écume l'écume des choses
c'est le plus important d'une
association c'est parce qu'elles sont
c'est ce qu'elles font et on est à
chaque fois sur une politique en
direction de de la structure de avec des
vieux débats qui sont qui sont très
intéressants mais sur la reconnaissance
de l'engagement etc c'est effectivement
des choses qui sont importantes j'espère
que vous aurez des succès sur sur ces
sujets là mais c'est des sujets qui sont
pas nouveaux et on voit pas forcément
arriver de des recettes des recettes
très nouvelles j'ai deux questions je
m'en tiendrai là la première elle
concerne la charte la charte de laïcité
je voulais savoir si vous aviez
un premier bilan de de ce qui s'est
passé sur le nombre d'associations
signatrices ou qui ont le musée de
signer et les conséquences que ça peut
avoir sur le soutien à ces associations
et la deuxième parce qu'on parle des
budgets de millions du fdva ou de
programme jeunesse mais aujourd'hui il y
a plus de 2 milliards d'euros de d'aide
souvent de défiscalisation en direction
des associations est-ce que sur ces 2
milliards qui sont quand même
la partie
immergée de l'iceberg est-ce que vous
avez là aussi des éléments de bilan ou
d'information qui nous permettraient de
voir si sur ces aides là on est sur la
bonne voie aussi il y a des
améliorations qui faudrait apporter je
vous remercie Julien barjoton
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
les ministres de votre présentation et
vos explications moi je me réjouis ça
vous surprendra pas de un budget qui est
en augmentation alors certes évidemment
c'est pour des objectifs qui sont pas
partagés enfin en tout cas partout ici
il y a eu des commentaires mais en tout
cas moi je voudrais quand même souligner
l'importance désormais de ce de ce
budget de ce programme
j'insisterai sur un point qui n'a pas
été beaucoup évoqué alors certes c'est
pas un gros budget puisque c'est 4
millions 100 euros pour les centres de
ressources et d'information des
bénévoles qui progressent quand même de
près de 50% donc c'est une hausse très
très considérable sur un budget qui est
qui joue un rôle dans l'écosystème
important puisqu'il forme il conseille
ils accompagnent les bénévoles et ils
soutiennent leurs projets donc je pense
que c'est un élément qui peut aussi être
souligné et j'en profite pour demander
peut-être est-ce qu'on pourrait
quel est votre vision sur l'application
de la loi du 1er Juillet 2021 en faveur
de l'engagement associatif
quels sont les fruits que portent cette
cette loi pour vous dans les grandes
lignes sur sur ce enfin on synthèse je
veux dire évidemment des éléments le
plus important notamment parce que de
cette loi facilite la gestion au
quotidien des associations par les
bénévoles je terminerai par un
commentaire qui est que moi je partage
l'idée de contrat et quand il y a une
contractualisation il y a des droits et
des devoirs et donc c'est normal que
lorsqu'on est avec un partenaire avec un
tiers et bien si on s'engage les
engagements vont dans les deux sens et
donc ça me paraît aussi nécessaire quant
à la fois de visibilité mais aussi de
d'action citoyennes de responsabilité
dans la société et bien on demande
également des engagement aux
associations ça paraît naturel dès lors
qu'il y a contractualisation il y a
forcément un ensemble de droits et de
devoirs qui sont attachés merci beaucoup
Céline Brulat
merci président merci mesdames les
ministres
sur le SNU
vous nous mettez dans l'embarras si je
peux le dire ainsi madame la ministre
parce que nous voilà à quelques jours de
voter des crédits c'est un secret pour
personne que ici nous avons quand même
depuis le départ quelques doutes sur ce
SNU que vous nous dites aujourd'hui
qu'il ne répond pas ou très
imparfaitement ces objectifs de mixité
sociale qu'il ne répond pas ses
objectifs de cohésion nationale et on
peut le comprendre sur un si faible
nombre de participants et vous nous
dites et je vous remercie de votre
franchise que vous êtes devant un choix
qui est soit on le généralise et on sait
tous ici que c'est effectivement entre 1
milliard cinq et un milliard 7 de
dépenses induite ou et c'est là que je
voudrais que vous nous éclairiez
davantage on l'intègre autant scolaire
je vais peut-être mal le dire parce que
je suis pas sûr d'avoir tout compris via
l'éducation civique et morale qui est
une matière où on fait rentrer quand
même beaucoup de choses ces derniers
temps à chaque fois qu'il y a je vais le
dire comme ça mais vous vous me
connaissez désormais chaque fois qu'il y
a une nouvelle mode on met ça dans
l'éducation morale civique
vous nous comme on dit chez moi vous
nous en avez dit trop ou pas assez
et donc
est-ce qu'il est vraiment
utile que nous doublions encore les
crédits du s&u comme ça a été le cas
toutes ces dernières années pour que
finalement vous tranchiez le sujet que
vous venez de mettre sur la table dans
quelques semaines ou quelques mois donc
je j'aimerais avoir quelques éléments
là-dessus
sur la jeunesse toujours alors je je
connais comme tout le monde ici le
périmètre de ce programme 163 mais je ne
peux pas
enfin on ne peut pas je crois
aujourd'hui évoquer la jeunesse sans
évoquer un problème majeur aujourd'hui
qui est la conséquence de la crise
sanitaire que nous venons de vivre qui
est la santé mentale des jeunes or mon
inquiétude c'est que je n'ai pas vu
grand chose dans le PLFSS qui vient
d'être adopté je n'ai pas vu grand chose
dans le budget de l'Éducation nationale
et on a eu le plaisir
de recevoir le ministre de l'éducation
nationale il y a quelques jours et je
non je n'entends pas non plus grand
chose aujourd'hui sur ce sujet or ça me
semble être un enjeu absolument
déterminant sur la vie associative
je trouve que ce budget alors je
pourrais rejoindre des tas de choses qui
ont été dites sur la lisibilité sur le
sentiment que on est fleur des sujets
mais que on a du mal à voir des choses
un peu structurantes je crois que ce
budget mes estime aussi là encore les
effets de la crise sanitaire sur un
certain nombre d'associations pas toutes
il y en a qui très bien redémarrer
profitant au contraire de l'appétence
des gens qui avaient été privés de vie
sociale pendant longtemps il y en a
d'autres qui sont vraiment mal en point
et ça ça mérite je pense une réflexion
et des mesures un peu structurelles et
puis sur l'inflation
les coûts énergétiques pour les plus
grosses associations mais l'inflation
des prix des denrées du quotidien pour
de nombreux associations et je ne vois
pas non plus beaucoup de enfin c'est
compliqué de dire aux responsables
associatives qui va y avoir on les
trouve toujours insuffisante mais des
mesures en direction des entreprises des
mesures en peut être en direction des
collectivités des mesures en direction
des citoyens et puis pas grand chose en
direction des associations et puis
dernier mot pour relayer mais tout le
monde connaît bien ces sujets là ici
les attentes de booster les éléments de
formation des bénévoles
parce que il y a vraiment beaucoup à
faire de ce côté là sur la VAE dont que
vous avez développé madame la ministre
je crois que les heures d'accompagnement
qui sont consacrés sont insuffisantes
c'est hyper compliqué aujourd'hui pour
un bénévole de faire valider des acquis
de l'expérience et je crois que les
heures d'accompagnement sont
insuffisantes et puis relayer c'est mon
dernier mot le fait qu'il faudrait je
pense
revoir le l'aide au poste fongep LED
post par poste parce qu'on est quand
même là sur des niveaux qui ne sont
assez faibles par rapport aux enjeux que
ça représente pour les associations
merci
Sylvie Robert
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
serai très bref parce que je m'associe
vraiment aux propos de mes collègues
ecoutez moi je suis assez frappée de
voir que le discussion que nous avions
l'année dernière sur les CNU se répètent
encore cette année sans que rien ne
change et que pire pire pire les
objectifs et vous l'avez dit vous même
n'ont pas été tenus
et vous avez des objectifs qui sont
l'année prochaine certes de doubler mais
à l'échelle ça n'a pas de sens c'est pas
du tout l'objectif qui prévalait à
l'origine à la création du SNU donc un
moment où on s'interroge sur la question
des finances publiques où on voit bien
que dans nos on est à la commission
culture et sport que dans le secteur
culturel sportif on a besoin d'avoir des
crédits supplémentaires notamment par
rapport à la question énergétique par
rapport à la question de l'inflation
écoutez un moment on se pose vraiment
des questions et moi j'ai une question
très simple est-ce que vous voulez
vraiment continuer le s&u alors même que
l'évaluation et ça fait quand même un
certain nombre d'années que dans cette
commission et à l'occasion des auditions
que nous avons avec vous ou même les
rapports budgétaires on se pose des
questions vraiment de la pertinence de
ce dispositif
donc ça c'est vraiment une question
écoutez vraiment que je me pose eu égard
à l'ensemble des des observations que
l'on a moi je suis rapporteur pour avis
sur le budget culturel je peux vous dire
qu'à un moment je m'interroge je
m'interroge
d'autre part sur la question la vie
associative
ou même du service civique je pense que
u égard et notre collègue c'est une
première vient de le dire lui égard à ce
qu'on vient de vivre et notamment les
jeunes et les associations même si dans
un certain nombre d'endroits oui les
associations ont repris les adhérents
mais pas tout vraiment pas tout hein le
secteur associatif est loin d'avoir
repris son rythme de croisière d'avant
la pandémie vraiment donc là aussi je
pense que même si les crédits augmentent
mais je ne sais pas si ils sont à la
mesure sur la question du service
civique l'augmentation de 4% n'est pas à
la hauteur de l'inflation donc alors
même que les jeunes là on pourrait du
coup leur permettre de réintégrer
tout ce qu'offre le service civique et
singulièrement pour le secteur
associatif moi je m'interroge vraiment
beaucoup sur sur les choix qui ont été
faits et une fois encore sur la question
du s&u vraiment eu égard au budget
énorme qui est qui est en tout cas celui
qui est proposé encore sur sur
en mesure nouvelle sur ces 30 millions
d'euros j'aimerais que vous nous disiez
vraiment ce que vous en pensez
Claude
merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames Messieurs critère
d'État je suis par là
moi je par rapport à ce qui était dit je
partage beaucoup de choses et
contrairement à Julien barjoton je serai
un peu plus nuancé en ce qui concerne
l'augmentation de ce budget il y a
certes une légère augmentation comme
vient de dire
Sylvie Robert loin du de
l'inflation et surtout le développement
de l'aviation ce budget lui est en
légère baisse
c'est peut-être Pinette mais c'est
important
ce crédit ce crédit quand même dédié au
soutien de la vie associative alors que
le contexte actuel de crise impact
significativement ce le tissu associatif
faut savoir que ce tissu représente 21
millions d'adhérents 13 millions de
bénévoles et 1,8 millions de salariés
soit pas moins de 10% des emplois privés
je pense que qu'il ne faut pas oublier
ceci
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne
la sanctuaire sanctuarisation du fdva
les crédits sont retours reconduits à
hauteur de 50 millions d'euros mais
c'est un dispositif qui reste cependant
et vous l'avez dit vous-même très
complexe pourquoi ne pas flécher ce
dispositif vers les élus qui ont une
approche plus fine de leur territoire et
là aussi on note qu'il y a beaucoup
d'instruments
qui sont mises en place pour une
stratégie globale qui reste floue et
donc de cohérence de d'ensemble des
politiques où égard au nombre sans cesse
croissant de dispositifs il faudrait
peut-être repenser et pourquoi pas
simplifier
on a parlé du bénévolat
et du conte d'engagement citoyen qui est
censé l'encourager le valoriser mais ce
compte voit ses crédits très largement
sous consommés et la dotation donc pour
2023 et en forte diminution alors la
question qu'on peut se poser est-ce que
ce compte a vraiment un impact sur le
bénévolat d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes
recommande d'examiner l'opportunité du
maintien de ces dispositifs où en
êtes-vous de ce côté là
et
[Musique]
je rappelle que nous avons fait un
certain nombre de propositions lors de
l'examen de la loi démocratisé le sport
des propositions de mesure valorisant
l'engagement bénévole
comment les appréhendez-vous et ne se
laisse pas le moment de les mettre en
œuvre
toujours en ce qui concerne le bénévolat
nous avons un temps fort qui se profile
ce sont les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
ne serait-il pas opportun de profiter de
ce temps fort pour promouvoir justement
le bénévolat aujourd'hui
en ce qui concerne l'action en faveur de
la jeunesse et de l'éducation populaire
moi j'ai une question ce qui concerne le
dispositif mentorat qui a été créé en
2021 un jeune un mentor doté de 27
millions d'euros cette année
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler du
bilan de ce dispositif où en sommes-nous
et puis pour la SNU je ne vais pas
rentrer dans le détail mais je pense je
rejoins notre rapporteur Jacques Bernard
Magnier je pense qu'il est opportun
d'avoir un débat quant à son éventuel
pérennisation et surtout à sa survie
et enfin Sonia de la pauvreté
oui merci beaucoup juste une petite
question dans votre ma question
s'adresse à la Ministre en charge la vie
associative vous avez dans votre
présentation évoquée data asso qui est
une start-up d'État
et vous savez au Sénat on est très
vigilant sur ces fameuses startups
d'État donc j'aimerais avoir des
précisions sur cette start-up d'État
data asso qui a quand même récupéré
toutes les données de toutes les données
de toutes les associations en France
et dont
l'entreprise qui a mis en oeuvre data
asso et donc une entreprise voilà
synaltique qui a un certain nombre de
partenaires dont un certain nombre
appartiennent à la Silicon Valley et
donc comme toujours le rgpd n'étant pas
le Cloud Act il nous paraîtrait
important de connaître les personnes qui
interviennent dans la mise en oeuvre de
ce data asso en dehors du ministère bien
sûr et dans quelles conditions les
caisson préserver conserver ou
précisément et
est-ce qu'il y a une réelle protection
de ces données vis-à-vis des
associations qui les ont fournies je
vous remercie
voilà toutes les questions ont été
posées je ne sais pas dans quel ordre
vous voulez y répondre
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président alors on
verra peut-être commencer par le service
national universel puisque c'est celui
qui pose le plus de débats le plus de
questions et je pense qu'on va on peut
revenir à la base même du projet le
service national quand il est imaginé
initialement il doit répondre à trois
enjeux d'abord augmenter la résilience
de notre pays ça veut dire quoi très
concrètement permettre de prendre
l'ascendant sur des situations
extérieures en créant la culture de la
défense en permettant à l'ensemble d'une
génération de maîtriser les gestes qui
sauvent de permettre à toute une
génération de s'approprier aussi une
culture mémorielle et patrimoniale
un deuxième élément qui est absolument
essentiel c'est de faire vivre un temps
de mixité sociale et territoriale ce que
nous n'arrivons pas à faire en réalité
en dehors aujourd'hui à quel moment un
jeune qu'il soit dit Île-de-France un
jeune d'Île-de-France rencontre un jeune
d'une autre région en dehors en dehors
du temps scolaire nous n'avons pas
accéder à de la santé avec un bilan de
santé qui est qualitative un
accompagnement de ses conséquences là et
enfin comment on répond à la culture de
l'engagement
dans cette commission en particulier et
vous avez raison ça va faire trois ans
qu'on revient sur un certain nombre de
sujets on se dit comment on fait plus de
bénévoles comment on crée cette cette
fougue chez les plus jeunes pour que il
s'inscrivent sur le temps long au sein
de nos associations comment on fait pour
soutenir et bien les 10 qu'on connaît
chacun dans nos départements pour qu'ils
aient des volontaires qui viennent
s'engager comment on fait pour que fasse
au désarroi de l'engagement démocratique
dans nos communes et bien il y ait plus
de jeunes qui viennent dans nos conseils
municipaux jeunes dans le fond on pose
ces questions et on se dit peut-être
quand conjuguant des petits bouts de
dispositif on y arrivera
ou pas ou pas et donc le projet qui
était celui du service national
universel au début c'est de dire il faut
ce grand creuser républicain il faut un
temps d'égalité réelle d'égalité d'accès
à l'engagement quel que soit son
territoire quel que soit sa situation
sociale parce que non nos enfants n'ont
pas accès de la même manière à aux
colonies de vacances non pas accès aux
mêmes offres culturelles sur les
territoires le capital social des
parents fait que malgré les aides de
colo apprenantes bien ils envoient ou
pas leurs enfants alors moi je viens
pour le coup d'une culture éducation
nationale et donc les ça a été mais
comment on fait le renouveau des classes
nature des classes découvertes bien sûr
qu'on peut et bien sûr qu'on le qu'on
les soutient mais est-ce que ça permet
de à tout le monde de partir la réponse
est non les familles les plus aisées
mettent leurs enfants en colonie de
vacances ou en départ de ces jours
linguistiques à Brighton et les familles
les plus défavorisées pour certaines ne
laissent pas leurs enfants partir ou si
elles acceptent de les laisser partir et
bien ils laissent partir dans des
dispositifs sociaux où il n'y a pas
cette mixité attendue et donc ce SMU
c'est cette promesse de et bien oui une
fois dans ta vie en tant que jeune
citoyen tu auras la chance et bien de
vivre le premier départ de vivre le
départ de ton de ton département un
temps de cohésion de faire d'apporter ce
goût de la mobilité mais aussi de lutter
contre le nom recours de parler de
sujets qui sont difficiles à l'école
aujourd'hui de parler de la laïcité du
non recours au droit de parler du
harcèlement de parler du
cyber-harcèlement du consentement des
sujets qui sont en réalité beaucoup plus
facile à évoquer quand on est en dehors
de sa classe parce qu'il n'y a pas la
pression de ses camarades le contexte en
réalité scolaire où on a un cousin un
ami un voisin qui fait que la libération
de la parole n'a pas lieu ça c'est le
projet social du service national
universel alors ceux qui ont connu le
service national de l'époque disent à
grand regret oh à l'époque on
rencontrait des gens différents en tout
cas c'était la seule fois on faisait des
bilans d'illettrisme bilan de santé bien
sûr que cette question là se pose
aujourd'hui et on pourrait très
facilement vous dire vous savez
l'investissement dans la médecine
scolaire nous permettra de répondre à
tous ses besoins non c'est les deux en
même temps et l'opposition du
développement du service national
universel avec le soutien à l'éducation
populaire et en réalité un faux débat
jamais le budget de l'Éducation
nationale a été a été aussi important et
aussi élevé 3,6 milliards d'euros
d'augmentation cette année le ministère
des armées a vu lui son budget augmenté
de 3 milliards d'euros est-ce que le
budget du SMU vient se substituer à
notre budget la réponse est non
service civique augmente de 20 millions
d'euros le l'éducation populaire
continue à être soutenu à plus de 15
millions d'euros et puis je vais revenir
sur un point peut-être essentiel quand
je dis que un jeune le séjour de
cohésion plus la mission intérêt général
plus la phase d'accompagnement
d'engagement supplémentaire c'est 2100
euros par jeune puisque ça a été la
question posée par madame la sénatrice
ce n'est pas 2100 euros de dépenses
sèches c'est en réalité l'intervention
d'associations d'éducation populaire et
donc c'est aussi une manière de soutenir
cette éducation populaire allez dire à
Léo Lagrange au Francas au PEP qui
interviennent dans ces séjours de
cohésion parce que c'est aussi le
soutien de leur modèle économique quand
on intervient dans l'heure centre de ces
jours quand c'est eux qui en réalité
permettent à leurs animateurs de venir
encadrer ce magnifique séjour que ce
n'est pas utile ou que dans le fond ça
ne répond pas à une question
de cohésion nationale et cohésion
sociale sur ce point là moi ce que je
vois c'est que je reconnais la
difficulté quantitative elle est réelle
mais est-ce que le SMU n'est qu'une
question quantitative la réponse est non
aujourd'hui si on regarde les analyses
qualitatives du sénu et donc les études
de l'INJEP par exemple 9 jeunes sur 10
sont satisfaits ou voire très satisfaits
de ce séjour parce qu'ils vous disent
j'ai rencontré des jeunes différents
j'ai appris des choses que je n'aurais
jamais appris ailleurs que j'ai
découvert finalement le champ des
possibles qui seront qui sera le mien
dans notre pays qui alimente aussi un
goût en réalité et bien de patriotisme
de fraternité cette fraternité elle doit
un moment avoir un goût des saveurs des
souvenirs alors il y a les jeunes qui
ont la chance d'avoir des parents qui
les mettent soit dans des colos soit
dans le scoutisme ou soit dans le monde
associatif et les autres
on les regarde et on les laisse
finalement vivre à côté de ces formes
d'engagement ce n'est pas ma conviction
et autant un séjour comme un projet
comme celui-là qu'un projet de société
oui prendre du temps et oui demande un
certain nombre de débats bien sûr mais
ne se construit pas tout seul et
monsieur le sénateur dessus quand vous
dites quand vous signifiez un certain
nombre pour le coup de situation qui ont
été sur lesquels on a pris des décisions
immédiates les encadrants du service de
Strasbourg ont été virés le lendemain de
la prise de compte quand j'ai pris
connaissance de ces informations là
comment on comment on y remédie avec une
formation plus forte évidemment mais
aussi je ne souhaite pas qu'on reste sur
la caricature de certains points ou
certains cas il y a eu plus de 150
centres qui ont été ouverts 32 000
jeunes l'année dernière qui ont vécu ce
séjour de cohésion alors je ne laisserai
pas imaginer que le séjour de cohésion
ou le SMU est une est un échec non c'est
une réussite pour ces jeunes et je vous
invite à les écouter à les recevoir à
les laisser témoigner de ce ont vécu ils
seront certainement meilleurs
ambassadeurs que moi de ce projet mais
ce que je vois c'est que quand on a
conscience du défi aujourd'hui
climatique et du besoin de créer cette
culture de la résilience oui par rapport
à ces jeunes qui aujourd'hui vivent de
les quantités et qui subissent d'une
certaine manière le sentiment de ne pas
pouvoir réagir de mal leur donner les
moyens de réagir s'il y a une inondation
dans leur dans leur commune dans leur
village parce qu'ils seront s'inscrire
dans une chaîne de commandement de la
protection civile leur permettre d'avoir
les premiers réflexes en cas d'incendie
ou en cas de en cas de tornade de mains
face à au risque de sécheresse c'est
leur permettre en réalité de s'inscrire
dans un parcours de citoyenneté et je
vous invite mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs au-delà des questions tout à
fait légitimes sur le quantitatif et je
reviendrai sur les différentes limites
de discuter avec ces cadets de la
gendarmerie qui est la mission qui est
la phase 2 du SMU avec ses jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers qui s'engagent avec ces
jeunes qui rejoignent la nacelle et donc
les conseils municipaux jeunes le
souvenir projet qui viennent revigorer
le le les cérémonies mémoriales sur nos
communes parce qu'ils ont découvert des
choses qui jusque maintenant ne leur
était pas proposé le SNU c'est aussi une
un projet effectivement ambitieux où on
ne laisse pas l'engagement au hasard ou
on cultive ce goût de l'accès à
l'information l'accès à son destin c'est
pour ça que l'engagement de la phase 2
et 3 et bien ça va jusqu'au 25 ans du
gène et donc pour répondre à ces enjeux
la mixité sociale elle s'améliore elle
ne sait pas c'est pas un échec elle est
en voie d'amélioration premier séjour de
cohésion 4% de jeunes qui viennent des
quartiers populaires février 2022 7%
presque on n'est pas loin de doubler
la moyenne c'est neuf plus de jeunes
effectivement qui viennent aussi des
lycées professionnels mais quand je dis
que quand on a eu plus d'inscription que
John qui sont venus au séjour de
cohésion de l'année dernière c'est aussi
toute la transparence que je dois la
représentation nationale pourquoi parce
que certains nombre de séjour était
pendant le bac de français parce que un
certain nombre de séjour était aussi
pendant les stages professionnels des
lycées professionnels et c'est pour ça
que cette année les séjours sont aussi
faits en février en avril dans des
moments où
des jeunes au parcours qui ne sont pas
des parcours de lycée généraux et bien
ont aussi ce temps leur permettant de
s'engager moi je ne peux pas entendre un
jeune me dire je souhaite participer à
un séjour de cohésion mais je ne peux
pas Madame la Ministre parce que l'été
je travaille où j'ai un stage
professionnel à faire et donc finalement
malgré ma volonté mais je ne peux pas
m'inscrire dans cette dans cette
démarche ma mission est mon enjeu c'est
aussi de revenir après trois ans
maintenant de ces d'organisations de
séjour devant la représentation
nationale avec un bilan avec des
témoignages des parents qui témoignent
de ces enjeux mais aussi l'éducation
populaire elle-même qui aujourd'hui est
parti prenante du référentiel de
compétences que nous sommes en train de
mettre en oeuvre quand vous avez des
grandes structures des grandes
fédérations qui vous disent aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin d'une jeunesse qui
repart en colonie de vacances mais on a
besoin de vivre le premier départ le
essai nu et ce premier départ entre
autres et donc conjuguer avec
l'éducation civique et morale c'est
simplement construire ce parcours de
citoyenneté tout au long de la vie
en tout cas du jeune du jeune citoyen
concernant les différents éléments de
résilience nous avons aujourd'hui plus
que plus que jamais besoin je crois
d'aller construire aussi ce service
civique nouvelle continuité nouvelle
génération déploiement complémentaire ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire engager plus
d'entreprises dans la meilleure
connaissance des compétences acquises
dans le service civique combien de
jeunes encore aujourd'hui nous disent si
j'avais su que ça existait je l'aurais
fait mais il y en a beaucoup trop
le et c'est nu et ce temps d'information
permettant de découvrir toutes les
formes d'engagement et si demain un
jeune s'engage dans cette phase 2 et
bien il prend pleinement sa part dans sa
capacité de prendre son destin en main
l'objectif plus que jamais du SMU et on
aura évidemment l'occasion d'y revenir
monsieur le Président si vous le
souhaitez avec une rentrant sur le
projet pédagogique sur le référentiel de
compétences sur les évaluations
sociologiques qui ont été faites par
l'INJEP au-delà du point quantitatif je
vous assure mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs que plus que jamais moi ce que
j'y vois c'est une opportunité pour
notre pays de construire de la cohésion
nationale de construire un nouveau pacte
entre les générations et oui un projet
comme celui-là
percuté par un certain nombre voilà de
de réalité covid de déploiement bien sûr
ne peut s'inscrire qu'avec la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
éducatifs
associatif bien sûr toujours et
aujourd'hui parce que je suis au sein
également rattaché au sein du ministère
des armées et du coup ça répond d'une
certaine manière à la question du
sénateur Vial nous avons besoin de
répondre à toutes nos jeunesses il y a
une partie de la moyenne d'âge au sein
de nos armées c'est 23 ans donc
permettre à des cadets à des escadrilles
air de l'armée de l'air ou encore je
pense plus largement à nos lycées nos
lycées militaires de permettre à toutes
nos jeunesse de trouver simplement la
place qui est la meilleure pour eux
parce que c'est là où s'épanouissent je
crois que c'est ça la promesse
républicaine ce n'est pas de créer de la
hiérarchie comme on a beaucoup trop fait
entre les lycées généraux les lycées
professionnels ou les lycées agricoles
c'est simplement de proposer à notre
jeunesse le chant des possibles qui
aujourd'hui est accessible et que il
s’épanouissent là où c'est fait pour eux
et donc l'inscription de ce projet en
tout cas dans un dans un parcours
ce qui m'amène en réalité à répondre
aussi à la question qui a été posée sur
le tutorat et le mentorat aujourd'hui le
tutoriel mentorat a atteint plus de 100
000 jeunes qui ont été accompagnés 27
millions de budget un collectif mentorat
qui qui a créé en réalité un écosystème
qui permet d'accompagner des jeunes sur
les territoires ruraux comme sur les
territoires
urbains et qui a vocation en tout cas
c'est notre souhait et bien de doubler
le nombre de jeunes accompagnés parce
qu'on voit à quel point quand tu as une
personne qui parfois te fait confiance
t'accompagne et ben ça t'ouvre parfois
le premier emploi c'est tout parfois les
conseils qui te permettent de lutter
contre l'autocensure mais aussi d'avoir
cette oreille attentive qui te permet de
ne pas être freiné dans ta vie citoyenne
et professionnelle
concernant également un sujet qui je
sais tient à cœur en tout cas leur
présentation nationale et qui a été
répétée plusieurs fois sur quelle est la
vision de la jeunesse aujourd'hui
l'effort budgétaire pour la jeunesse
c'est 100 milliards d'euros
tout budget confondu enseignement
supérieur politique de prévention de
santé le chèque psy les bilans de santé
les politiques vie étudiantes c'est 100
milliards mais quel est le document qui
permet ça c'est le jaune budgétaire
effectivement madame la sénatrice vous
avez raison le budget que je porte avec
ma collègue Marlène Schiappa pose la
question de l'engagement et donc de la
politique en faveur de la jeunesse avec
un biais effectivement et ce jeune
budgétaire permet la consolidation
générale mais il y a un outil qui peut
être je crois encore plus musclé demain
c'est la clause d'impact jeunesse
outil qui est doté qui aujourd'hui est
le fruit de la d'une de la loi de 2016
et qui peut devenir en réalité encore
plus ambitieux sachant qu'en plus nos
collègues en tout cas mes collègues
européens mais portent la question du
USA pack c'est-à-dire la clause d'impact
jeunesse européenne c'est une c'est une
chance pour aller chercher la priorité
jeunesse partout dans l'ensemble des
textes dans l'ensemble des politiques
parce que quand on pense une politique
mobilité il a des conséquences sur la
jeunesse quand on pense une politique
hébergement il y a des conséquences sur
la jeunesse et donc avant peut-être de
poser ce débat dans sa globalité je
crois que la consolidation du du budget
se pose plutôt dans ce jeu de budgétaire
et c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé mes
propos par notre budget 163 est une
fraction de l'engagement de évidemment
du gouvernement mais plus lajorité plus
plus largement de l'engagement de tous
pour la jeunesse parce que je passe même
pas et je pourrais je pourrais parler
pendant des heures de l'engagement des
collectivités enfin avoir de la jeunesse
conseil régionaux conseil municipaux
conseil départementaux Genève a besoin
particuliers les jeunes de l'ASE les
jeunes de la qui dépendent de l'APJ les
jeunes qui aujourd'hui sont soutenus par
les municipalités le blog communal avec
le passage du passage le passage du
permis de conduire voilà l'engagement
aujourd'hui de notre pays pour notre
jeunesse et donc très modestement la
ligne 163 n'est en réalité qu'un petit
bout du fruit de cet engagement en
faveur des jeunesses de France parce que
plus que jamais je fais le choix de ne
pas parler d'une seule jeunesse parce
qu'elle est bien diverses elle a des
besoins particuliers
mais chacune à sa place chacune a un
destin à construire et plus que jamais
construire cette fierté d'être français
et donc d'être capable de lutter contre
ces déterminismes sociaux par
l'engagement je crois et le fil rouge de
la mobilisation qui est la nôtre
monsieur le Président j'espère avoir
répondu aux questions qui ont été
principalement posées par les sénateurs
merci Madame peut-être pour quelques
éléments de précision par rapport
je vais je pensais que c'était un 17h30
et j'ai un engagement derrière donc je
partirai à 17h50 j'espère que vous ne
m'en voudrez pas mais je suis bien sûr à
votre entière disposition j'ai un taux
de réponse aux questions écrites
d'environ 100% depuis le début du
quinquennat précédent et je suis bien
sûr à votre disposition si vous
souhaitez qu'on se rencontre pour
approfondir certains sujets mais je vais
tenter de répondre à tout ce qui a été
soulevé d'abord monsieur sénateur adossu
sur la question du contrat d'engagement
République moi je crois au contrat
d'engagement républicain je l'ai porté
en tant que ministre dans la loi lors du
précédent quinquennat d'ailleurs il
[Musique]
qui m'ont dit que au-delà de la case à
cocher sur le CERFA on leur demandait de
le recopier ailleurs dans m'adresser des
exemplaires signés pour telle ou telle
formalité et ça clairement c'est un
dévoiement de la loi tout simplement
donc nous on a demandé à ma collègue
madame Sonia baquet la ministre qui est
désormais en charge du contrat
d'engagement républicain de bien vouloir
réunir dans son ministère une réunion de
points d'étape avec les associations
d'ailleurs c'est un engagement que nous
avions pris ensemble avec Sarah elri au
moment du passage de la loi et donc nous
avons demandé à notre collègue qu'elle
puisse réunir ses associations pour
faire ses remontées de mise en oeuvre et
s'il y a des problèmes qu'on puisse
apporter des solutions très concrètement
pour l'exemple d'alternatiba j'ai pris
l'alerte du mouvement associatif j'ai
regardé ce dossier il y a eu aucun
retrait de subventions par alternatiba
ou demeurant c'était la collectivité qui
finançait cette organisation donc la
cible c'est bien véritablement le
financement de l'islamisme radical le
financement de trouble à l'ordre public
c'est ce type d'action et évidemment pas
des associations qui me porteraient
famille contraire à celle du
gouvernement politique mange peu vous
donner des dizaines voire des centaines
d'exemples d'associations qui sont
financés par l'État et qui critique dans
leur plaidoyer l'action du gouvernement
y compris de façon virulente et c'est
normal j'en veux dire ça le
fonctionnement de la démocratie on n'a
jamais donné une association dans les
ministères dont j'avais la
responsabilité en fonction de avez-vous
un plaidoyer pro ou anti-gouvernement et
encore une fois les exemples si vous les
souhaitez je peux vous en donner il y en
a légion donc véritablement ce contrat
d'engagement républicain je vous invite
à regarder à cette réunion qui se
tiendra pour voir comment on peut la
mettre en place sur le volet
interministériel monsieur le sénateur
Vial oui évidemment le fait que il y ait
un rattachement à Matignon donne cette
impulsion interministérielle mais je
vous confirme que les crédits destinés à
subventionner les associations secteur
par secteur reste piloter par les
ministres c'est la ministre de l'Égalité
femme homme qui adressent les
subventions sur inégalité c'est la
ministre que je citais chargée de la
citoyenneté qui adressent les
subventions par exemple sur la question
de la dérive sectaire c'est au ministère
de l'Éducation nationale ou au ministère
des armées qu'on subventionne les
associations dans le champ de ce secteur
nous nous subventions non pas les
associations pour leurs activités
sectorielles nous subventionnons
l'accompagnement à la vie associative
donc les têtes de réseau associatifs la
structuration de l'engagement associatif
donc c'est très clair et tout comme pour
ma collègue Sarah Laris ça représente
évidemment une infime part des
subventions qui sont adressées par
ailleurs je veux préciser que sur la
question du fdva les préfectures
connaissent parfaitement la vie
associative je veux défendre les préfets
les sous-préfets et les agents de
préfecture et d'ailleurs les
parlementaires sont présents au sein des
collèges départementaux et participent
ainsi aux orientations en apportant
leurs éclairages et si ça n'est pas le
cas n'hésitez pas à me le signaler afin
que je puisse le faire remonter au
préfectures concernées parce que c'est
extrêmement important qu'il être présent
sur la question de l'énergie moi je veux
être très clair sur ce que vous avez dit
madame la sénatrice brûlant vous dites
vous dites les entreprises sont
soutenues les citoyens pas les
associations je me permets de vous dire
respectueusement que c'est faux au
contraire la première ministre Elisabeth
borne dans sa dernière prise de parole
tant sur le bouclier tarifaire que sur
les aides face à la hausse de l'énergie
à bien inclut les associations et
d'ailleurs elle en a été remerciée par
les têtes de réseau associatif et nous
étions à cet égard dans une grande
banque alimentaire en déplacement où
elle a réitéré cet engagement donc les
associations bénéficient tout autant des
aides et des boucliers des dispositifs
mis en place par le gouvernement pour
les protéger face à la hausse de
l'énergie c'est important de pas leur
dire le contraire parce que sinon elle
passe à côté d'un droit dont elle
dispose pour être protégée face à
l'énergie c'est dans le le budget ya
ferrant en matière d'énergie donc ça me
semble très important monsieur sénateur
barjoton sur la loi de 2021 porté par
Sarah lairi par ailleurs je veux dire
une des mesures l'un plus importante
mais je parle sous son contrôle la
protection des dirigeants bénévoles en
matière de responsabilité financière ça
me paraît là aussi être indirectement un
élément d'attractivité du secteur
associatif beaucoup nous disaient cette
responsabilité elle nous pèse elle est
très forte c'est un risque que nous
prenons sur nous intuitif personnel
c'était une demande de terrain attendue
depuis plusieurs années qui a été porté
et voté par la représentation nationale
et moi je trouve qu'elle porte ses
fruits en tout cas en toute objectivité
ce n'est pas moi qui ai porté cette loi
pour le coup je trouve que c'est une loi
efficace qui est plébiscité en tout cas
par par les acteurs qui s'expriment sur
ce sujet en ce qui concerne la question
de la start-up d'État data asso madame
la sénatrice de la Pro BT je vais vous
donner les éléments dont je dispose
s'ils ne sont pas complets je vous
invite à pouvoir revenir vers moi parce
que je vous dis très humblement les
éléments dont je dispose et peut-être on
peut aussi organiser un rendez-vous avec
l'administration directement si vous
souhaitez qu'on vous montre peut-être
plus en détail la manière dont
fonctionne data asso et donc fonctionne
la start-up d'État si vous le souhaitez
c'est bien sûr tout à fait possible donc
c'est un partenariat il s'agit de donner
qui proviennent du greffe des
associations donc ce sont des données
publiques qui concernent ces
associations qui sont centralisées là et
elles sont ensuite stockées au ministère
des affaires sociales ça fonctionne via
une budgétaire de fonctionnement et
numérique de la vie associative qui a
doublé justement pour pouvoir avoir
encore davantage de données et c'est je
crois un outil intéressant alors qu'il
doit être amélioré sur le volet
promotion de la vie associative locale
et notamment en permettant aux
collectivités d'avoir un onglet
véritablement dédié c'est à dire qu'on
va pas chercher des données
confidentielles ou qui ne seraient pas
connues on va chercher vraiment de la
donnée publique et aller centraliser à
un endroit sur ce sujet alors il y a des
travaux en cours pour intégrer justement
les associations qui ne sont pas au
registre national en raison de
spécificité je pense à l'Alsace Moselle
ou à la Nouvelle-Calédonie mais encore
une fois si vous voulez plus de détails
et je comprends par votre signe de tête
que vous voulez plus de détails on est
au disposition avec l'administration
pour convenir d'un rendez-vous pour
qu'on puisse vous apporter techniquement
tous les éléments de réponse que vous
souhaiterez avoir je vous remercie
bien merci mesdames et secrétaires
d'État pour ces réponses précises à nos
questions et nous examinerons demain
matin le l'avis du rapporteur sur les
crédits qui vont concernent merci
beaucoup merci